well tonight we're getting our first
look at nevada's plans for the covid 19
vaccine rollout the state detailing how
the vaccine will be given out over the
next couple of months
sasha is back to explain how it's all
going to work out
in a matter of days we will see the
covid 19 vaccine here in las vegas
i believe it's incredibly important you
just don't feel comfortable
i don't feel comfortable whether you're
for or against it state leaders released
a 112
page plan friday detailing exactly how
it will be distributed these doctors who
want to be able to go home and see their
family instead of going home and staying
in a different room
they are going to need they need all the
help they can get
the first of a three-tier process makes
this month's
160 thousand rounds created by pfizer
and moderna
available to our healthcare workers and
most vulnerable populations
so each can receive the necessary
two-shot dose
the second phase which could come as
early as january
would include anyone else at risk with
the third and final phase expanding to
our entire community
by the spring of 2021 unless you're on
the front lines which i have nurse
friends who are
you don't really see the effects supply
will be limited at the very start
which means most of us will have to wait
a while longer
but those we spoke with say they're
looking forward
to what's next the more people that get
it the quicker we can go back to normal
sasha loftis 8 news now